when scientists assess new variants
before deeming them variants of concern
they look to see whether the new
mutations are able to do three things
one make the virus resistant to the
effect of the vaccines
two make the virus more transmissible
when compared to existing variants
three
make people more sick if they were to
contract the new variant
the omicron variant has more mutations
than any previous variants many of which
are on the spike protein the part of the
virus it uses to bind to and infect
human cells
the most widely used vaccines pfizer
moderna oxford astrazeneca are based on
getting our immune systems to recognize
the spy protein part of the coronavirus
as foreign if the mutations in the
omicron variant change the sky protein
enough so that our immune systems can no
longer fully recognize it then it may
mean there is a degree of immune escape
for this variant but the chances of it
rendering previous protection useless is
extremely low and it is far more likely
the vaccines will continue to offer a
good degree of protection from even this
variant
recent surges in new infections in south
africa where the omicron variant has
been identified has raised serious
concerns over increased transmissibility
of this new variant particularly in
younger people
although still too early to know for
sure it looks as though the mutations
omicron has may make it more
transmissible when compared to delta
there is currently no data to support
that those that are infected with
omicron suffer any different symptoms to
those who caught and were infected with
previous variants and there are some
reports that it may actually result in a
milder illness than delta though we need
more data on this
there are a lot of unknowns at play
right now but scientists are working at
record speed to get a better
understanding of the omicron variant and
what it might mean for the pandemic
precautions taken now will mean we can
keep things under control until we
understand more about this variant